تحت قوس على علاقه باسطوره من اساطير همم
المونديال حيث اعلنت مصادر اعلاميه
برازيليه انه اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
بيلي لم يعد يستجيب للعلاج الكيميائي وانه
تم نقله الى الرعايه التلطيسيه اضافت
بدايه المصادر ان ااه هذه المرحله من
العلاج تعتمد على رعايه المرضى في الحالات
الصعبه عبر اجراءات تخفيف الالم وضيق
التنفس فقط وذلك بعد ما كان بيلي قد دخل
للمستشفى البرت اينشتاين في ساو باولو يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي لاعاده تقييم لعلاجه من
سرطان القولون الذي كان قد تم تشخيصه
بالاصابه به في سبتمبر العام الماضي
نظام الينا جميل حسان مسعود مراسل الجزيره
من مستشفى البرت اينشتاين في ساو باولو
يرحب بك حسان لك ان تضعنا في صوره تطور
الحاله الصحيه
للاسطوره بلي
بالفعل المعز بعد هذه الاخبار التي
تداولتها مواقع وصحف مرموقه هنا في
البرازيل حول الحاله الصحيه لنجم البرازيل
بيلي قبل قليل اصدر هذا المستشفى البرت
اينشتاين هنا في سو باولو بيانا حول حالتي
بليه الصحيه ربما يكون مطمئنا الى حد ما
له جمهوره ومحبيه اكد خلال له ان حاله
النجم بلاي مستقره انه استجاب
للعدوى او العلاج الذي كان مضاده للعدو
التنفسيه التي كان يعاني منها عندما ادخل
الى المستشفى وانه دخل لمتابعه وتقييم
علاجه من سرطان القولون الذي كان يعالج
منه منذ سبتمبر عام
وان الحاله الطبيه حتى هذه اللحظه خلال ال
24 ساعه الماضيه لم تتدهور وفقه البيان
الصادر قبل دقائق من هذا المستشفى مستشفى
البرت اينشتاين همم هذا البيان ايضا مشابه
للبيان الذي كان قد صدر يوم امس في الثاني
من ديسمبر الجاري الذي ايضا كان قد اكد ان
حاله بيليه الصحيه همم هي همم حاله مستقره
وانه يخضع للعلاج من عدوى في الجهاز
التنفسي وهذا يخالف ما تحدثت عنه
المعطيات التي تحدثت عنها عدد من مصادر
صحفيه ووسائل اعلام صحفيه من بينها صحيفه
سوريا
داخل هذا المستشفى المعطيات الرسميه كما
ذكرناها اما المعطيات التي تتحدث عنها
وسائل الاعلام تخالف ذلك لان ابنه في اخر
تصريحات همم لها قبل ثلاثه ايام كانت قد
اكدت ايضا ان حاله همم ليس الطارئه همم او
فيها ما يدعو لي القلق واضح حسين والعالم
كله همم يتابع الحاله الصحيه لبيليه
وشاهدنا همم حتى همم صوره بيلي والرساله
التي اتته من هنا من الدوحه من ابراج
لوسيل والتي لاقت استحسانا هناك في
البرازيل حتى من عائله لنفسه شكرا لك حسن
مسعود كنت معنا همم من ساو باولو